celle de l' empire colonial français il
y a tout juste un siècle des images d'un
autre monde d'une autre époque qui lie à
100 ans commence tout juste à circuler
la france est alors à l'apogée de son
ère coloniale un empire exceptionnel par
sa taille conquis bien souvent par la
force et dirigé par la contrainte
[Musique]
l' empire va atteindre sa plus grande
superficie plus de 10 millions de
kilomètres carrés lempire produit ce
qu'on attendait de lui après avoir donné
des sommes pour la guerre ils donnent
des produits des minerais des matières
premières pour la métropole
c'est ça qui se passe à partir de 1920
or on en a eu 20 ans de ce qu'on appel à
projet colonial et l'écran exposition
qui vont dès 1922 à marseille dès 1924 à
strasbourg ou à bordeaux en 23 vous
commencez à expliquer aux français qui
sont une grande puissance car il possède
le second empire colonial au monde avec
une francs à ce que tous les enfants de
france vont écouter dans les années 20
le soleil ne se couche jamais sur l'
empire colonial de la france
nous avons décidé de nous plonger dans
quelques-unes de ses photographies
vieille d'un siècle
d'abord pour comprendre ce qu'elle
raconte et puis aussi histoire d'ouvrir
les yeux sur ce qu'il reste cent ans
plus tard de ses premiers regards sur le
monde de l'outre-mer français
[Musique]
1914 le crépuscule s'abat sur la planète
entière
la grande guerre et ses 10 millions de
morts et vingt millions de blessés
un cataclysme qui va laisser toute
l'europe à genoux
l'un des plus grands traumatismes de
l'histoire de la planète qui ne va pas
épargner l' empire colonial français
malgré son isolement géographique
[Musique]
première guerre mondiale et amandes
bascule fondamental pour la france il
n'y a que deux pays en fait qui ont fait
appel à leurs colonies pendant la
première guerre mondiale la grande
bretagne et la france
pourquoi pour un problème démographique
la france et l'angleterre ne sont pas
capables de rivaliser face est immense
allemagne avec ces populations à
l'époque le déficit démographique est
quasi du simple au doux son cas solution
c'est de faire venir des dizaines voire
des centaines de milliers de combattants
pour venir combattre l'allemagne la
première guerre mondiale
c'est aussi la première vraie rencontre
des colonies avec la métropole
un million d'hommes tous issus de l'
empire colonial débarque sur le sol
français pour participer à l'effort de
guerre
à partir de là rien ne sera jamais plus
comme avant
[Musique]
l'après-guerre sonne pour beaucoup comme
un nouveau départ
comme si certains survivants de 14-18
avait besoin d'une thérapie pour se
débarrasser des séquelles laissées sur
les corps et sur les âmes par cette
guerre interminable reprendre tout à
zéro et partir à la recherche d'une
nouvelle vie dans le vaste empire
colonial français
silhouette à la française nous sommes
dans des territoires du western français
tout est possible situé chouette avis
ici tu l'as réussira là bas il y a un
peu cette idée d'un grand ouest qui
s'ouvre français à l'époque
partir à la conquête de l'ouest
certains ne vont pas hésité bien
longtemps d'autant plus qu'à l'ouest
justement il y à ce territoire presque
vierge qui intrigue une terre de
souffrance c'est certain mais pas
seulement la guyane c'est la troisième
île dans l'imaginaire collectif
elle se résume à une chose d'essentiel
le bal
meetic et ses lèvres après le célèbre
panda jeu 1923 ou un écrit à
l'inhumanité dans l'inhumanité
[Musique]
personnes veulent migrer en guyane on
n'a pas envie d'aller en guyane sauf
pour une raison fort parce que la guyane
est une terre riche 10000 orpailleurs et
chercheur d'or sont présents dans toute
la guyane
on présente à l'époque la guyane comme
une terre qui doit rester des millions
de richesse de potentialités mais c'est
une terre de western
on n'a pas envie d'y être
[Musique]
l'arrivée du premier avion a fait
l'objet d'une chanson en 1922 dégarni
bull ce qu'il décrit dans ses paroles
c'est exactement ce que les les
pionniers en russie en guyane sont des
vols intercommunaux et lorsque l'avion
est arrivé la première fois à cayenne
témoigne thomas était fasciné d'ailleurs
toutes les affiches de propagande montre
les habitants de cayenne de l'inini qui
regarde là qui regarde cet objet céleste
l'a probablement à l'époque de
l'identifier ça devait être un instant
dindonneau venir parce que les gens
n'aient pas de la culture aéronautique
c'est la photo d'un événement
considérable pour la guyane
une véritable révolution qui va marquer
à jamais l'histoire de l'aviation
12 octobre 1919 la foulée rassemblés à
cayenne pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'outre-mer français une
compagnie aérienne vient de faire un vol
commercial
2h30 à peine pour relier saint laurent
du maroni à cayenne avec trois passagers
à bord la tag la compagnie des
transports aériens guyanais est né
sur la droite un parti ouest se trouvait
la chambre de commerce un magnifique
bâtiment de style colonial un étage
effet en brique qui a été détruit dans
les années 1980-90 là nous arrivons
exactement se trouvait le site web donc
la zone de gérer cette phase
d'atterrissage de l'avion
une fois qu'il avait amerri on pouvait
le mettrons en cale sèche à ce site web
et puis débarqué les marchandises dans
de bonnes conditions pour la tag
l'objectif c'est une rivière lointaine
perdu dans la forêt amazonienne à plus
de 250 km au sud de saint laurent du
maroni
cette rivière celi
un nom qui attire tout ce que la fièvre
de l'or a contaminé nous sommes au
sortir de la première guerre mondiale
nous sommes en 1919 la guyane a produit
de l'or pratiquement 10 heures durant
cette période par année et par
conséquent évidemment les hommes
d'affaires sont forcément au courant et
ils se disent c'est peut-être l'occasion
jamais d'investir en guyane et d'aller
capter une partie de la production d'or
pour atteindre ce but
latta gâchette 6 hydravion des surplus
de la première guerre mondiale a mené
par bateau depuis la métropole
mais pour piloter de tels engins il faut
des as
l'un d'entre eux s'appelle pierre région
j'ai découvert ce beau noir
c'est un beau mec bel athlète
région il était non seulement pilotes
mais était aussi mécanicien de bord il
fait partie des cinq seuls pilotes noirs
de la guerre 14-18 avoir guerroyé fait
la guerre donc c'était quelqu'un des
souvenirs pour moi ce sont des héros
mais le 15 août 1920 l' aventure
s'arrête brutalement pour pierre région
son appareil se crashe dans le fleuve
maroni
le tuant sur le coup un coup dur de plus
pour la tag déjà plombés par de graves
problèmes financiers
la toute jeune compagnie sera dissoute
quelques mois plus tard après seulement
trois années d'existence
je pense que c'est le rendez vous raté
d'une épopée extraordinaire et en même
temps je dirais
un immense gâchis technologique animant
gâchis culturel et donc on les prend 8
monpierre pompiers sur le pouce et 6 mai
[Musique]
quatre appelés à 40 cents ans plus tard
rien n'a changé presque
l'avion est toujours indispensable ici
et la guyane est devenu une sorte de
carrefour au dessus duquel un grand
nombre de vols se croisent enfin petit
tour de table
l'huile et au village à décoller et tu
l'as dit de rappeler qu'en haut vol
d'air d'accord raconte 36 son prochain
appel c'est quoi c'est les dix équipes à
la tour de contrôle de cayenne on va
s'occuper de deux types des espaces
d'abord l'espace qui est dans le rond là
qui s'appelle l' approche va tout
rapproche donc on va préparer les
descente d avion
les montées et ensuite on a eu notre eau
notre espace où on gère deux types de
contrôles on va vérifier que tous les
avions qui vont sur les petits terrains
les petites réalisations guyane
maripasoula à grand santi ça laurence à
hull
on va vérifier que tous les avions sont
arrivés à destination
[Musique]
et ce n'est pas tout chaque jour plus
d'une centaine d'avions survolent le
territoire français d'amazonie
on a du trafic qui vient par exemple des
etats-unis vers l'amérique du sud des
états unis vers l'afrique du sud ou
encore de l'europe
le plus gros flux c'est de l'europe vers
l'amérique du sud
donc tout ça c'est du survol sont pas
des avions qui vont se poser chez nous
et on va les croisés vérifier qu'ils se
rendent pas les uns dans les autres
[Musique]
et
un terrain de jeu grand comme la moitié
de l'atlantique
[Musique]
deux fois l'espace aérien de la france
métropolitaine le ciel duisanais est
immense alors ses côtés je suis là que
j'ai bien pris pour la clôture vous me
rappeler au départ de petits sont des
tout-petits si on veut se déplace à
wigan
si on veut aller voir un petit peu
ailleurs on est obligé de prosnes âge
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il fera
si effectivement du quotidien les gens
ils sont habitués à prendre l avion
c'est voilà c'est quelque chose de
commun parce qu'on s'y sent cette route
directe s contact
la présence de soldats servant
mariam en gagnant gagnant
si on est on est quand même une terre
vrai à ces enclaves et déjà nous vivent
à cayenne c'est compliqué de se déplacer
et pourtant voilà en histoire et les
reports donc en avion c'est assez facile
mais moi je pense aussi aux autres
lyonnais qui gisait à l'intérieur des
terres quand on va vers maripasoula ou
encore plus à saül n'y a pas de route il
n'y a pas de fleuves l'avion c'est
vraiment le seul et unique moyen de se
déplacer d'avoir aussi un apport en
matériel en nourriture tous patrons pour
vivre on a besoin aujourd'hui en guyane
d'avoir des avions
les pionniers avaient vu juste il ya
cent ans
sans avion tout serait plus difficile
pour la guyane
[Musique]
guillaume et pascal l'ont bien compris
ils font partie de ces pilotes
expérimentés pour qui la guyane vue du
ciel n'a plus aucun secret des milliers
d'heures de vol à eux deux et une
admiration sans limite pour ces
pionniers de la tag qui ont ouvert la
voie des airs
il ya tout juste cent ans qu'est ce que
tu nous donnes s'il trouvait ça lâche à
tout jeune marc onno van sant l'onu
morny la première ligne est relié
cayenne à saint laurent saint laurent et
nini ensuite et vues prises à bord d'un
hydravion nous plégat volet déjà il ya
son temps dans ce qu'on a à la bête avec
la préfète et des bras tout à fait
brésil 14 et la troisième version je
crois des actions qui ont été achetés
par la tag 1920 1921 nous ce qu'ils nous
diront va dire dans l'hydraviation c'est
la capacité d'atteindre 50 de surface
1,52 zone de poser en guyane donc qu'ils
sont toujours aussi mal
des services qui sont souvent très
enclavé avec peu de moyens de
communication peu de moyens de détection
radar il ya toujours un petit esprit
aventurier quand il ya toujours ce
sentiment de liberté quoi continue mais
la haine et des gaz en avant et tu
d'école il ce bol des clients général
qu'ont fait voler c'est le wahoo tout de
suite et même même nous en bout de temps
heures de vols on est sur une fois que
je décolle c'est super cool allez on
n'est jamais lasser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pascal et pilote instructeur sa mission
apprendre aux autres a volé prendre les
commandes d'un avion pour pouvoir
contempler l'amazonie depuis les airs
[Musique]
mais jean la flotte
c'était quelque chose que je voulais
faire donc j'avais les moyens de faire
l' endroit pour le faire parce qu'il y
avait encore de la place il y avait
personne qui faisait ça enfin un titre
professionnel
puis ça a fonctionné c'est comme
beaucoup de choses en guyane à partir du
moment où on met de l'énergie
ça fonctionne
[Musique]
oh
une énergie que pascal consacre aussi à
transmettre en donnant le goût de volée
aux plus jeunes
bonjour les enfants c'est bon bienvenue
à bord
[Musique]
allez pouvait descendre tranquillement
droite et gauche et des enfants qui
viennent faire une lecture avec un lien
commun de l'aviation et des idées et des
vibrations
aujourd'hui je vais vous demander
d'imaginer que vous êtes un pilote et un
copilote et vous allez écrire un carnet
de vol on va s'imaginer aviateurs
pilotes comme ça récupérer ou comme les
pilotes de l'aéropostale qu'il ya 100
ans ont rallié saint laurent à cayenne
en hydro en hydravion pour la première
fois parce qu'en plus vous allez chacun
avoir la chance de voler empire sur le
manche il monte on pousse sur le manche
il descend on pas et après de droite et
gauche ça va nous permettre de faire
tourner l'avion ferraille pour les
enfants c'est tellement magique à deux
volets d'être dans un hydravion en plus
je sais c'est presque petit avion de
tintin à quoi donc voilà il ya le côté
côté super sympa quoi ok allez à cheval
oui c'est comment ton prénom
layana c'est joli ça sa tâche pour pas
de perdre
ça va à la pêche ouais ouais c'est un
petit peu tendu un qui a la fenêtre 6
pers mil
c'est pas
[Musique]
fabiana vie
à voir
2 3
en vain
le pilote démarre le moteur les zélés se
met à tourner après on te sens tu as
l'air sur le visage
[Musique]
la bataille
moi je ne pilote l'ia je suis monté dans
un hydravion est et vu le paysage dans
l'est c'est magnifique
j'aime la grandeur de la foudre un
horizon loin la beauté des villages une
vue du ciel il ya cent ans les pionniers
de la tag été les premiers à découvrir
la guyane vue du ciel
un siècle plus tard ses enfants perpétue
ce rêve un rêve de liberté en somme
cette même quête qui nous a traversé
l'esprit
en contemplant ses photographies
centenaire
[Musique]
mais le vaste empire colonial est
incompatible avec la liberté
la politique est ainsi fait que le rêve
n'a jamais sa place quand c'est la
conquête qui s'exprime alors tant pis
retour à la réalité
[Musique]
1870 la france entre dans la troisième
république
le temps de la conquête coloniale bat
son plein portée par quelques hommes
politiques
jules ferry léon gambetta tous vont se
jeter dans une bataille pour construire
et structurer la seconde puissance
coloniale au monde juste derrière les
britanniques
qu'est ce que vise par là l'état
français comme tous les ans bien
l'autonomie économique sur la plaie le
marché autarcique
c'est un marché qui pourrait presque
fonctionné sur lui même
le rêve idéal de ne pas dépendre des
autres car je peut exporter des produits
manufacturés dans les colonies
donc la route shon pour l'économie
française métropolitaine et je peut
importer de ces territoires coloniaux
qui me coûte donc zéro plutôt que
d'importer les pays limitrophes de la
france et la logique des économistes des
planificateurs des technocrates de
l'époque c'est d'imaginer un empire
idéal qui aurait pu rendre tout à fait
autonome le métropole la france se lance
donc dans une planification méthodique
obsessionnel même dans cette course à
l'expansion économique
chaque territoire doit avoir sa propre
utilité
aux antilles c'est la canne à sucre qui
attise toutes les convoitises
mais cet or vert est menacée par un
séisme qui pourrait bien tout remettre
en cause
peu de gens se sont posé la question de
ce qui s'est passé après 1848 par
exemple pour les vieilles colonies one
look martinique réunion avec l'abolition
de ce carnage
ce qui s'est passé c'est simple c'est la
fin de l'apport de nouveaux bras pour
l'économie de saisie au fond et oui mais
les anciens esclaves allez pouvoir
travailler alors premièrement les
anciens esclaves sont dans un état de
fatigue corporelles à capable de
travailler et pour les mettre
il ne correspond pas à une main d'oeuvre
jeune productive
on les laisse à l'abandon pour la
plupart d'entre eux ils ne vont pas être
recyclés dans l'économie coloniale
donc on va chercher de nouveaux bras aux
antilles par exemple ça va faire naître
l'engagisme parce que jusque peu de gens
connaissent quand fait d'aller chercher
des travailleurs sous contrat qui fait à
peu près se retrouver dans des
conditions sanitaires et de travail qui
était pas loin de celle des esclaves et
qui en fait payer leur voyage vers les
îles avec un temps de travail
obligatoire 3 en 6 ans 9 ans pour les
maîtres qui les avait fait venir
[Musique]
l'une de ces communautés va bénéficier
d'une des décisions les plus
extraordinaires de l'histoire de la
colonisation guadeloupe 21 avril 1923
l'état français régularise toute la
communauté indienne sans exception 43
mille indiens au total qui ce jour là
deviennent français une décision à
l'origine de laquelle il y à cet homme
[Musique]
photo de sa femme photo d'harry 80 ans à
peu près henri si dambach homme fils
d'immigré indien ce nom va rester gravé
à jamais dans les annales des droits
civiques en guadeloupe et dans tout
l'outre-mer français
l'une des plus connues comme une pause
wallah alors sa photo en son entier les
autres sont on le montre un peu plus âgé
pratiquement dans les dernières années
de sa vie
henri si dambach hommes consacrent une
grande partie de sa vie à ce combat à
l'issue incertaine permettre à sa propre
communauté d'accéder enfin à la
citoyenneté française
quelques dizaines d'années seulement
après avoir émigré en guadeloupe
mais le combat de cet humaniste va même
bien au delà en russie d'un bar homme
c'était l'un des plus grands défenseurs
des droits civiques de l'époque les
engagés indiens alors il a été en
politique mais projet une courte période
5 en 1897 1900 1902 il a été un conte
humaniste parce qu'elle était juge de
paix après la deuxième guerre mondiale
jusqu'à sa mort le crâne de donc toutes
les personnes qui avaient des soucis
contre les grands propriétaires terriens
du problème avec eux l'état colonial où
les gones administration venait le voir
et donc durant toute sa vie s'est
préoccupée des humbles les personnes les
plus démunies les pauvres toute sa vie
s'est défendu contre les pour les
opprimés
le combat d'une vie avec à la clé la
victoire
ce grand jour où ils sont tous devenus
enfin français les indiens de guadeloupe
l'ont attendu près de 70 ans
depuis que laurelli le tout premier
bateau de migrants indien débarque 310
d'entre eux en guadeloupe
nous sommes à la veille de noël 1854 a
proposé quelques parodies là la france
en lui disant bombe écoutez vous invitez
de faire venir des gens d'afrique
en contrepartie je vous donne
l'autorisation de recruter des indiens
sur le territoire anglais de l'aisne et
l'histoire l'immigration en guadeloupe
commence effectivement à 1854 avec ce
bateau de loreidy dans le sillage de
laurelli des dizaines de milliers
d'indiens vont suivre le même chemin
pendant toute la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle une gigantesque opération de
recrutement de main d'oeuvre agricole
indienne qui va s'étaler sur près de 35
années c'étaient des gens qui avaient
également un peu l'habitude de
travailler sous l'autorité de quelqu'un
a même en inde donc culturellement de
trouver un patron
je le dis oh ça laisse des salles est
dépaysé pas trop c'est le voyage qui les
dépayser et d'ailleurs on retrouve ça un
petit peu dans les propos des écolos
qui disent que ma foi les indiens soient
vraiment la meilleure mais d'oeuvre
qu'on n'ait jamais trouvé ils sont
dociles ils sont gentils ils coûtent pas
cher et cetera et cetera
une aubaine pour l'état colonial
français qui organise en inde un
recrutement méthodique selon les besoins
des planteurs de canne à sucre de
guadeloupe
le tout en partenariat avec le
gouvernement britannique
si on appuyait les mots d'aujourd'hui on
parlerait clairement d'une politique
publique parce que c'était une politique
réglementée avec des invités des décrets
des lois qui réglementent et tout ça et
c'était également une politique
subventionné l'esclavagé a été aboli
certes mais les conditions de travail
très dures dans les plantations n'ont
pas beaucoup évolué seule nouveauté les
engagés indiens ont signé un contrat de
travail avec l'administration coloniale
cinq ans au total
à l'issue desquelles il existe une
option de retour
ça a très peu manche et singulièrement
en guadeloupe
non pas que les indiens qui sont restés
voulais rester mais s'il y avait
toujours une bonne raison de ne pas les
envoyer n'y avait pas d'argent ce
n'était pas prévu au budget il y avait
toujours une très bonne les gens qui
faisaient que bon en fait il ya eu en
tout et pour tout moins de 10000 rothau
en devenant français la plupart des
indiens sont donc restés en guadeloupe
six générations plus tard leurs
descendants sont toujours là certains
ont même conservé le métier de leurs
ancêtres vous demandez à ian mahinmi
chaoui ça fait plus de 30 ans je suis
ado j'avais depuis que j'avais le fait
au moins 87
mon père a pu en moi qu'ils avaient le
potentiel parce qu'il menait ce les
petits marchés et je voyais pas mouillé
l'exercer et donc le fait qu'il a arrêté
la botte de légumes il a collé c'est
parce que j'étais la belge avait 18 ans
il avait de l'énergie et donc j'ai gardé
cette continuité là avec mes clients et
la maintenance api jours
voilà profitait profiter tout ça qu'il a
c'est un euro sur tous les légumes
soient au top ligne à 2 5 euros
comment la communauté indienne at elle
gardé ce contact avec la terre c'est ce
que nous avons cherché à savoir avec
gérard krishnasamy exploitants agricoles
de père en fils depuis que le grand père
a quitté l'inde natale pour immigrer en
guadeloupe nous en sept camps parce
qu'ils offrent depuis trois mois de
navigation pour venir aux antilles et à
l'époque des tempêtes tout ça donc je
pense que ils ont fait par un terrible
vraiment un truc dangereux
heureusement il y avait des survivants
là on ne peut que les remercier de
l'année parce que franchement faire ses
travers cela avec lee crochemore en
l'appelant cycle sur un indien
et puis revenu sur les antilles donc
c'est une fierté pour nous d'être là
pour gérard un seul impératif
restez connectés à l'essentiel le
travail la connaissance et surtout
l'amour de la terre une philosophie de
vie que marcel le père de gérard cultive
encore chaque jour dans ses champs à
plus de 80 ans
[Musique]
alors c'est lui c'est lui le formateur
c'est lui qui nous entourent non plus
depuis elle a jusqu'à z
et puis c'est lui qui nous a donné la
passion du travail l'amour de ce qu'on
fait la vente des légumes au niveau
élevage fille a pas photo quand il est
au fait si opéra vers les animaux et
c'est comme ça que j'ai appris à élever
les animaux montée ou même lui il était
spécialiste en la version un canasson
ils n'ont pas appuyé par livre ils ont
appris par au fur des années au fur des
années ils ont appris et quand ils sont
arrivés aux antilles il n'avait pas le
même climat donc il fallait gérer le
nouveau climat qu'on a ici
[Musique]
une histoire de transmission en somme
avec à l'origine de ce savoir faire
quelques agriculteurs arraché il ya plus
de 100 ans de leurs campagnes indiennes
et bassiste de l'ofce netiq je ne sais
pas mais l'amour donne à la terre
franchement de voir comment la meilleure
nous la mère nourricière nous donne à
manger nous donne nous donne tôt parce
que ça la terre noire n'aura rien quand
des fois on fait des labours on voit
comment la terre il est belle à ça ça te
dit tout de suite l'envi de travail
franchement c'est que du bonheur de
travail dans cette
[Musique]
bienvenue chez les beaux-parents cgra
et puis le temps a passé les générations
se sont succédées en guadeloupe
participants au passage au métissage de
la société guadeloupéenne et son père sa
mulâtre parce que le grand père enfin le
père de mon grand père c'était un
mulâtre avec des descendants breton on a
un vrai métissage dans ma famille à moi
et ensuite en épousant gira donc nous
avons eu des enfants qui sont aussi
métissé mais je dirais que le métissage
est moindre puisque mes enfants ils sont
typés plus avec les cheveux plats comme
les indiens
mais alors que reste-t-il de cette inde
lointaine resté quasi inconnu pour la
plupart de ces guadeloupéen descendants
d'indiens quelques vagues souvenirs une
part d'imaginaire aussi bref tous les
ingrédients nécessaires à la recette
d'une intégration réussie donc j'ai lavé
et si koné g assaisonner et je laisser
mijoter pendant la nuit au frais j'ai
acheté la pâte à colombes
même le plat national antillais trouve
ses origines dans la cuisine indienne du
19e siècle le colombo débarqué tout
droit du sous continent
il y a un siècle
moi mon grand père paternel j'ai vu
qu'il est né en inde en 1856 et il est
arrivé ici je ne sais pas si c'est par
l'uriné
il y avait ici et il a côtoyé une femme
antillaise
il a eu trois enfants reconnu mais
n'était pas marié à la bonne femme
un garçon et deux filles c'était
monsieur c'est aux gens vous lie boulaye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
indiens ils étaient en minorité ils sont
arrivés c'est en minorité en guadeloupe
est ce son est bien implanté ensuite
puisque ils sont il y en a certains qui
sont partis faire des études
on sait que c'était pas évident c'était
pas facile et en revenant aux halles ou
qu'on a vu qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des
hommes qui ont une influence importante
notamment au niveau de l'économie avec
des grands chefs d'entreprise si on est
là aujourd'hui c'est grâce à nos
ancêtres
je dis à ces gens là bravo ils ont bien
fait de choisir cette population là et
maintenant on voit le résultat
le résultat il est là et il n'y a pas
photo c'est des voix travailleurs et
voilà le chemin parcouru par la
communauté d'origine indienne
trois générations pour s'intégrer
pleinement et affirmer sa fierté d'être
guadeloupéens
honneur à vis de barum au nom de toutes
les divinités sont venus en guadeloupe
accompagné s'est engagé honneur à la
lumière quand c'est d'abord nous emmener
et a fait de ces immigrés des
guadeloupéens des français et qu'ils ont
tous les droits
hollywood bananas a dit ladjia n'est
jamais au courant soudas
[Musique]
nous serons guadeloupéens et nous ne
sommes pas des indiens vivant en
guadeloupe nous ne sommes pas des
africains vivant en guadeloupe ne sont
pas des européens lueurs de l'aube
nous sommes des guadeloupéens et ce peu
importe que et au métissage ou pas
soldes du guadeloupéen nous sommes nés
ici nous avons cette culture cette
culture là nous assumons le passé avec
tout ce qu'il a été de positif de
négatif et qui a donné la société qui
existe aujourd'hui
[Musique]
nous sommes d'ici une phrase qui prend
tout son sens quand on regarde ces
images qui défilent dans la pénombre
sur ces clichés centenaire
[Musique]
des regards des attitudes qui
revendiquent tous une appartenance une
fierté d'une histoire
mais pour la france colonisatrice il n'y
a là que des indigènes et le rouleau
compresseur de la colonisation va se
remettre en marche pour ramener tout le
monde dans le droit chemin d'une
prétendue civilisation
dans l'univers coloniale le sport a une
place essentielle
vous vous rappelez le sport a été créée
par des aristocrates britannique pour
jouer entre aristocrates britannique et
ne se mélangeaient pas avec les ouvriers
les aristocrates britanniques et
français sont aux colonies exactement
les mêmes le sport et le sport de
l'élite
c'est un sport de blancs et va naître je
d'un croix dans les années vingt deux
ceclad qui était extrêmement fermé aux
indigènes
on commence à ouvrir ces clubs
d'abord il va y avoir des
réglementations qui vont limiter le
nombre d'indigènes en éclat bien même
s'en rendre compte c'est quand même
totalement hallucinant mais vouloir
gagner et dès fois plus fort que
franchir la color line et vous allez
voir à travers tout ce temps des années
20 les années 30 émerger des clubs
totalement indigènes des clubs dits
mixtes et encore des clubs blanc est
donc un club indigènes qui affronte un
club blanc c'est la version réduite sur
un terrain de sport
la guerre chronique
une véritable révolution
quand on sait que la théorie de
l'infériorité des peuples colonisés
circulent encore largement à l'époque
mais la brèche est ouverte et les clubs
sportifs vont se multiplier en
particulier en martinique avec enfin une
opportunité pour ce qu'on appelle encore
les indigènes celle de se mesurer à
armes égales aux colons blancs et
pouvoir enfin les battre
[Musique]
on
un siècle plus tard la martinique est
devenue cette paire de champions
celle dont rêvait tous les pionniers du
sport qui dans les années 20 se sont
battus pour faire partie des premiers
clubs qui venait tout juste de voir le
jour
non je pense que ça a été la petite
sortie en vélo cité récupération tu peux
diot va mais bon ça va
ok bon là on va rentrer mettre les sacs
se doucher et puis un dans un mythe dans
une demie on est prêt pour aller
déjeuner ok photo m
et puis après midi un petit coup de
sieste après et puis on retourne rouler
avec junior ou senior que les jeunes
vont rester va opposer ce premier jour
de stage avec l'équipe à shaba games
donc c'est un stage à but de cohésion de
sensibilisation aussi pour les gamins de
se retrouver ensemble de profiter aussi
des vacances scolaires pour qu'ils
puissent découvrir autre chose et tu
leur apprendre encore des petites
notions du vélo et de perfectionnement
on met pas les deux jeunes en s'en va
les deux petits jeunes on l'aimé pas
sans mal et deux pour ce cas de tout le
temps semble déjà changer un petit peu
moi ce que j'aspire c'est à ce que tous
ils puissent réussir une carrière
sportive
malheureusement la loi du sport elle est
comme elle est donc il y aura peut-être
deux ou trois qui on va passer qui vont
passer à travers les mailles du filet
donc le bus et voilà 2 construit aussi
le jeune adulte le jeune homme pour
qu'ils puissent découvrir autre chose et
puis s'imprégner aussi du tissu local
quoi parce que ils sont tellement
immergée est tout au long de l'année
dans leur famille ou dans leurs
habitudes et la casse un petit peu ce
train train puis être autonome être
indépendants aient pu commencer à être
des vrais petits adultes
tous ces jeunes cyclistes sont venus
profiter de l'expérience du champion
martiniquais hervé arcade avec l'espoir
un jour de devenir professionnel on
vient d'arriver donc là sera pas conçus
au delà ce sera repos on va passer à la
douche et cet après midi on va on va
commencer à travailler
donc voila et puis au fur et à mesure
des jours on verra comment ça va se
passer parce qu'elle aussi les jeunes
docteurs on va pas tout faire avec eux
donc mon faudra aussi penser à eux donc
voilà c'est pas forcément des kilomètres
qu'on est venu prendre mais il ya aussi
savoir vivre ensemble tous à la cohésion
de groupe parce qu'il ya plusieurs via
cette personne je connais n'en connais
pas assez donc voila et puis apprendre
de nouveaux trucs
quand je vois le potentiel qu'on a au
pays est très sec mans ces gamins-là ils
ont déjà ce potentiel physique mais ils
ont des limites limites financières
limitent de contact et du coup ils se
perdent en chemin
moi je veux dire de façon très modeste
c'est être un petit peu le facilitateur
pour que ces gamins puissent exposer au
plus haut niveau 6 y arrive maintenant
c'est super voilà après c'est aussi
permettre à ces gamins-là de se dire là
demain je serai un jeune adulte il faut
que je sache que moi le vélo il ya de la
rigueur il ya des règles il faut je
respecte bien dans la vie de tous les
jours c'est pareil quoi
[Musique]
rouler pour se démarquer il y a un
siècle
d'autres s'entraînait pour obtenir la
reconnaissance qui leur était refusé
ce qui dans ses allées sombres de la
colonisation savait que le sport était
l'unique chance d'accéder enfin au plus
hautes sphères de la société
[Musique]
affaire des rôles à des gars maintenant
maintenant on va casser un petit peu les
coudes auront une meilleure pénétration
dans les en bresse de résistance au vent
il pourra faire tourner tranquillement
brac est libre mais sans accès aux quais
hervé garde pas censé avoir pour lui il
est toujours là à transmettre à
transmettre à transmettre
donc franchement c'est un chouette type
c'est un chouette entraîneur et c'est un
chouette gars aussi dans la vie de tous
les jours donc franchement quelqu'un qui
avait avec lui et la passe en même temps
que les coûts de la marée
voilà
on sait dès ce matin va cet après-midi
les plus anciens un stage c'est ça c'est
comme je vous ai dit un le but s'est pas
étonné qu'on est en plein coeur de la
compétition c'est pas de vous casser les
ailes et puis surtout vous faire la
fatigue créé la fatigue c'est simplement
vous prenez des habitudes donc quand
vous allez grandir
et puis changer de catégorie vous
puissiez quant à avoir des automatismes
c'est sale c'est un peu rébarbatif mais
c'est ça si on veut progresser c'est je
m'entraîne je mange je me repose je
m'entraîne je mens je me repose
[Musique]
les racines culturelles les racines
ethniques se sont déjà des athlètes à la
base et puis après le la population
antillo-guyanaise ces amoureux du sport
et après quand il y en a qui peuvent
pratiquer je pense que
être uniquement parlant génétiquement
parlant
ben voilà dès qu'ils avaient à pratiquer
ce sport qui est telle qu'ils soient
bien ses valeurs ressentent et quand ils
arrivent à trouver la discipline qui
leur corresponde à ce moment-là il
explose complètement
[Musique]
pour la martinique
c'est une journée pas comme les autres
qui débute une marque prestigieuse a
décidé d'installer ses couleurs bien
loin de chez elle
voilà aux trois ilets ici c'est paris
aux appliques toi sur le comptoir
oui bien joué ça barbu à les bienvenus
oui mais je ça ok paris est désormais
installée aux antilles le club de
football psg vient tout juste d'ouvrir
son académie en martinique avec une idée
en tête être aux premières loges pour
repérer les futurs champions on est là
pour s'amuser aussi faut vraiment
prendre plaisir à l'égard dont
consommaient pas de pression on est
vraiment no stress
ok ce que je demande c'est beaucoup de
concentration et surtout d'écouter ce
que demandent les coaches parce que faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui avec l'académie on
n'explique pas l'exercice deux fois on
explique qu'une seule fois
à la tête de l'académie
un ancien joueur professionnel de foot
milieu
garry bocaly connaît parfaitement la
valeur de ces très jeunes joueurs parmi
lesquels il pourrait bien déjà y avoir
la star de demain
les pluies cinéma allez allez lorenzo se
déplace
huit morts nés m'en aller c'est son
prénom la maman qui connaît rien au foot
elle a bien entendu ça à la télé comme
elle nous disait elle a trouvé ça beau l
appeler ma couette nous aussi un piège
academy on a notre nema on sait en tout
cas que les antilles c'est vraiment une
terre de champions
c'est une terrain qui a produit
énormément de joueurs des footballeurs
professionnels bonjean j'en fait parti
aussi donc je suis revenu justement pour
pouvoir partager ce que moi j'ai pu
connaître cette académie permet
aujourd'hui de pouvoir mieux former nos
gamins et pourquoi pas aujourd'hui si a
la chance d'avoir des gamins qui sortent
du lot pour intégrer le centre de
formation du psg du paris saint germain
ce serait vraiment un plus c'est toi la
nôtre mais qui peut tuer un des leaders
techniques accord donc j'ai effectué une
couronne activités hockey webpass toit
d'un wagon à chaque fois des ballons
auxquels étaient activités dans le lot
il y à un jeune prodige qui intéresse
particulièrement le staff de la psg
academy il s'appelle florian 15 ans à
peine tous les ballons passent par lui
n'ont qu'à pas technique mais là c'est
un militaire à gardez avoir les passes
mais c'est vrai que sur le sur les
dépassements il ne peut qu il un peu
limite où le mouvement est clair et net
intégrateur ccg allaient jeu légal et
c'est un gamin qui va sur ses 15 ans il
les a même pas encore et c'est vrai que
quand on le regarde sur leurs gardes
sans ballon on n'a pas l'impression que
c'est un joueur de foot comme il est
petit et un peu frêle mais c'est vrai
que quand on le met dans le jeu c'est un
joueur super intelligent donc c'est un
gamin qui a peut-être un coup d'avancé
des fois quand il a le ballon et qui ne
va pas faire l'effort de redemander
encore par la suite et c'est là
justement où on essaie de lui faire
comprendre il a déjà compris énormément
apprécié c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
rabâcher tout le temps le but de cette
académie aussi c'est de pouvoir donner
la chance aux enfants de rêver c'est pas
parce qu'on est sous une petite file
qu'on la voit même pas sur la carte
qu'on peut empêcher à tous ces enfants
un jour de rêver qu'ils peuvent jouer un
jour pas au paris saint germain
le but c'est de leur donner la chance de
pouvoir arriver de leur donner une
certaine formation pour pouvoir y
arriver parce que rêver c'est quelque
chose est arrivé c'est autre chose
gravir les échelons et se faire un nom
pour s'offrir une ascension méritée dans
la société
[Musique]
au cours du siècle passé de nombreux
dirigeants politiques vont faire
carrière en empruntant d'abord la voix
du sport pour se faire une place parmi
les élites
le sport a été le premier espace de
revendications politiques
c'est pour ça que ce sport va t'en se
développer parce qu'il va devenir un
espace pour fédérer pour structurer ou
compris la vie politique pour pouvoir
aussi accéder aux élites
parce que quand vous appartenez un club
de foot vous rentriez dans une forme
organisationnelle dans la société vous
commenciez à reproduire aussi le modèle
blanc donc les clubs sportifs vont se
démultiplier
[Musique]
c'était un autre monde une autre époque
c'était il ya cent ans les hommes
avaient imaginé le sport comme un
véritable instrument de pouvoir
mais tout ceci est resté bien loin
derrière nous
la figuration on va faire un exercice
qui est un peu spécifique lors d'une
arrivée au sprint et travailler ça donc
posté en binôme y en a un qui sera
lanceur 1 qui sera sprinteurs on va
inverser les rôles
d'accord
tout donner pour espérer pouvoir
atteindre un jour les sommets du haut
niveau et qui sait peut-être s'échapper
vers d'autres horizons
à moins qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont du talent qui peut qui peut réussir
est tout sauf que il faut absolument pas
rester ici parce qu'elle est la
diversité n'est pas assez importante en
fait le cyclisme se passe en europe
c'est cela qui a le niveau c'est là
qu'il ya toutes les courses
internationales
ah non vous êtes acat part d'un petit
peuple on accole content quand vous avez
fait au niveau des pêcheurs et là c'est
chacun pour soi
aller avec
m
la colonisation n'avait vu dans le sport
qu'un moyen de dominer d'écraser les
populations locales
c'était il ya seulement un siècle
mais vu d'ici ça ressemble plutôt à une
éternité
[Musique]
et c'est peut-être bien ce que ces
photos provoque sur nos yeux désormais
habitués à l'obscurité
elles finissent par brouiller la courbe
du temps
comme si tous nos repères même les plus
familiers s'effaçait devant ces regards
venu du passé
que peuvent bien reflété chacun de ces
instants figés par l'objectif une
réalité une mise en scène tout cela
semble bien trop beau bien trop lisse
toutes les images sont tous des
fantasmes elle fabrique une non réalité
une sorte d'immense mirage auquel les
gens vont croire parce que d'abord vous
croyez ce que vous avez envie de croire
quand c'est beau et vous croyez en même
temps que ces territoires à fantasmes
fonctionne nous sommes encore dans un
temps où la morale chrétienne et
catholique domine la société française
alors qu'aux colonies salle inverse
ce fantasme incroyable travers sa
société on pense que ces femmes nues
lascive attend l'homme blanc qui va
pouvoir venir conquérir les terres comme
et au caire les corps le fantasme absolu
de la conquêtes sexuelles
une utopie érotique qu'un territoire en
particulier va subir de plein fouet
[Musique]
c'est un mythe qui a traversé les
époques alimenté par cette imagerie
centenaire 1921
lucien gauthier photographe français
rentre à paris il vient de passer dix
sept en polynésie
dix-sept années pendant lesquelles il va
s'acharner à restituer le mythe d'un
éden paisible d'une féminité fantasmes
et celui là même sur lequel les premiers
explorateurs de l'archipel s'était déjà
fracassé ce mythe de la rennais qui va
avec les mets de traiter est née en
occident en france après le retour du
navigateur louis antoine de bougainville
et elle surtout la publication de son
livre voyage autour du monde
il a développé ce qu'on connaît sous le
nom de mythe de tahiti mythe de la
tahitienne et tout ce qui s'ensuit
de désagréables pour les femmes d'ici
depuis donc plus de 150 années
dès son arrivée sur l'archipel à la fin
du xviiie siècle
bougainville associe immédiatement la
tahitienne à la déesse vénus il l'a
décrit comme l'incarnation d'un amour
libre et innocent le tout dans une
nature paradisiaque
de quoi enflammer l'imagination des
européens des navigateurs il ne fait pas
la société polynésienne il avait ses pas
en passant quelques heures quelques
jours que il pouvait comprendre les gens
qui y vivent leur pensée comment ils
conçoivent et le monde conquis leur
langue
donc il était dans l'ignorance complète
in avec une impression extérieur donc
c'est une grande ignorance oim
[Musique]
vahiné la femme en tahitien tout
simplement
tout le reste n'est que légende de
cartes postales à trois sous smith est
quelque chose d'extérieur d'étrangers
d'occidental il y avait cette période on
a cru à ce mets donc si longtemps croyez
que sap
ça sent pas concerné vraiment là les
femmes d'ici et que donc les femmes
travaillaient à correspondre à cette
représentation là et puis il ya eu la
période on a été gêné parce que c'était
une atteinte même un autre à notre
identité un autre personnalité à notre
dignité de femme polynésienne dans et
puis il ya eu la période où on s'est
insurgé contre ceux là
- et puis on a compris que il fallait
pas s'y attarder
parce que ces mecs là ne nous concerne
pas ne nous appartient pas
[Musique]
et pourtant le mythe est tenace est
totalement indissociables aujourd'hui
encore du cliché du paradis polynésien
le marketing touristique en particulier
s'en est emparé parce qu'il permettrait
de mieux vendre la carte postale
polynésienne
pour comprendre l'impact de ce mythe sur
l'identité de la femme polynésienne
direction papara au sud ouest de papeete
c'est là que vit l'une des gardiennes de
la tradition et de la culture de
l'archipel polynésien hinatea colombani
est une spécialiste de la culture
polynésienne son objectif transmettre la
passion qu'elle a pour son territoire à
la jeune génération
ce petit point ce spot au fait je les
aime beaucoup on parce que ben c'est un
peu notre atelier c'est vraiment
l'espace où on voulait transmettre et
puis pour nous on fait la culture c'est
plus on fait plus sens pratique plus on
transmet et donc on voulait créer cet
espace là avec eux bah les enfants qui
fréquentent le centre mais aussi à des
scolaires qui viennent au centre culture
et à la wii que mon chéri on aime bien
faire cette blague que c'est mon
colocataire est au faîte dans le centre
culturel c'est grâce à lui c'est grâce à
ses mains c'est lui qui a reconstruit le
bâtiment et il faut savoir que le
bâtiment la récupérer les torrents green
petite anecdote en france durant mes
études pendant la pause vous faites un
gage haïm abord d india j'ai entendu
dire à la présentation enfin quand tu te
présenter et et haïtiennes qubo la
thalasso walsky sommet comme on dit
souvent chez nous c'est vraiment eu et
tawake enfin c'est vraiment tel que tu
me parles quoi de que là j'avais ma
capuche
je suis du coup bah il faisait voilà que
j'avais relevé pour protéger jeu h phie
quoi pour qu'ils en parlent et la nba
mais non mais parce que ben tahiti ça
fait rêver et c'est vrai que la chine a
way et est alors enfin je comprenais pas
le contexte mais en voyant sans regarder
c'est vrai que ma y voit autrement
finalement les
la femme de polynésie et la wii non mais
je rêve d'aller sur le cocotier sous les
cocotiers avec les marine et blanc
étaient là voie pas mené avec toi qu'on
est et c'est vrai que mais ils se
rendent pas compte que moneo il ya une
évolution
il ya une éducation qui je pense fait
que ben les vahinés d'aujourd'hui sont
plutôt indépendant de toute façon les
choses ont changé déjà et houba on
comprend pas cette image là quoi et on
la veut pas surtout
[Musique]
quand j'étais adolescente je voyais et
des cartes postales en c'était donc avec
des pirogues sur l'eau d'un ruisseau fin
d'une rivière ou bien sûr la mer avec
une femme en paraît donc les images que
l'on connaît quoi epinal et moi je ne me
posais pas de questions on s'est dit bon
c'est une représentation de la femme
alors peut-être comme ça que nous sommes
quelque part mais pas dans ce que nous
vivions nous au quotidien dans ce qui
montre bien que ça ne correspond pas à
la réalité
c'est une image sur fait on sent bien
que ça vient répondre à la tente des
touristes des gens extérieurs à la
polynésie
comment se débarrasser de cette image
tenace celle du fantasme d'une sexualité
libre celles alimentées par un autre
mythe celui du bon sauvage lui aussi
inventé de toutes pièces par les
premiers explorateurs qui voyait une
sorte d'idéal chez ces peuples inconnu
qui entretiennent un lien étroit avec la
nature
ça fait quatre ans qu'on vit sans
électricité parce qu'au fait ça nous
coûtait trop cher de faire installer
électricité jusque là où on invite et on
a décidé pas de tester une vie sans
électricité puis bon bah ça fait 4
heures je suis pas mort tout va bien on
a des toilettes sèches et au fait ça
nous a permis d'être plus au contact
la nature est donc le bas de comprendre
un peu mieux qu'un autre impact sur la
planète
[Musique]
et allemagne ou y ont été loi mais bon
concept mais oui là vient en plus avec
ce beau temps l'entente magnifique tu
vas pas le toit qui est là et on va
aller indiana jones
je t'ai suisse attention là ya tout un
piège c'est la première fois tu fais tu
tapes a donc d'abord pour commencer le
faudra et constitue le temps partout
d'autres bien que les communicants ont
fait et qui va jusqu'à la partie de
longchamp nature donc ton tapis sport et
tu es conscient que je pense quoi de la
glycémie de la marine et puisque l'on
m'a posé quelques questions sur sa toi
c'est quoi ton avis de ça je pense que
le mythe c'est ça fait son charme
ça fait son charme c'est vrai ça fait
parler de nous c'est mes balles encore
une fois c'est des croyances
ile-de-france mais pour venir chez nous
pour l'afrique ont fait que je vois la
tour pour rencontrer quatre mois une
ablution cette image c'est plutôt une
image c'est que je suis finalement but
de la femme tahitienne mais c'est mal en
point qu'en 2001 il ya aucun cette
question là quand je l'aï fait mes
études en france
oui je pourrais me jeter dans le dock
tgv donc il y avait il y avait un
monsieur là qui compte or il ya dix ans
mais vous venez de tahiti dit oui a dit
faire une danse oui bien sûr ça m'agace
ok mais moi je viens d'arrêter ça on
sait ce qu'on fait non à la poste du
soleil en fait dans leur guise haifa moi
je mets le pouce comme ça j'étais là
d'un homme immensément aller en taule et
à moi que j'ai vraiment envie de
partager la mère d'ander tgv la norme
exhibé là comme ça donc la matière mais
par ouais si le codi peut-être
exhibition qui nous dérange pas ce que
fait sa fausse il a appelé un peu les
zoos humains finalement pas où c'était
le bon sauvage qu'on rencontre et je
pense que ça nous verrons
je sa peau
une icône qui dérange inventé il ya plus
de deux siècles et demi par des
navigateurs occidentaux en mal
d'exotisme
comme si ces marins n'avaient pas réussi
à ouvrir les yeux sur la richesse de ce
territoire
quelque part la polynésie n'amène pas de
richesse dans l'imaginaire collectif
ces richesses ce sont ces populations
mais ces populations ne sont pas des
populations utile à la métropole d'abord
ce sont des îles très lointaines dont on
sait très peu de choses
certes ça nous fait penser au paradis
perdu à la gauguin ça nous fait penser à
des mondes d'altérité très lointaine
mais il ne rentre pas dans une logique à
caractère économique
la logique économique celle qui a
traversé les époques on s'en prendre une
seule ride
celle qui commence tout juste à se
mettre en place dans le début de ce
xxème siècle qui sera celui de la
mondialisation des échanges
celle qui va provoquer dans certains
territoires de l'outre-mer français
d'une crise sans précédent
[Musique]
une
et
[Musique]
c'est une île oubliée par la métropole
une vieille colonies datant du xviie
siècle qui a quasiment disparu
perdu dans l'immensité de la carte de
l'empiré colonial français
résultat au début du 20e siècle la
réunion est dans un état proche de la
féodalité la réunion la première guerre
mondiale a été d'abord une demande des
sommes incroyables 14 mille hommes sont
partis au front
c'est énorme pour la petite île ça
bouleverse totalement l'économie de
l'île
il ya une crise économique qui est liée
aux soucis de l'économie sucrière
il ya huit cyclone qui ravagent l'île
entre les années 1860 et 1890 à un
paludisme endémique donc la population
est en fait vis très mal et très pauvre
et ce n'est pas tout
printemps 1919 la réunion s'apprête à
vivre une catastrophe sanitaire sans
précédent
[Musique]
trois mois de cauchemar absolu
l'épidémie de grippe espagnole ramené
par les soldats de retour du fronton
frappe l'île un véritable cataclysme est
une gigantesque panique dont la
brutalité se résume en une seule photo
la grippe espagnole à la réunion a fait
quatre fois plus de morts que la guerre
où on n'imagine pas mais si vous voulez
comprendre en septembre le court no
virus et dans ces temps de grosses
angoisses médical ce qui se passe dans
la plupart des territoires coloniaux la
guerre ramène la mort et pas simplement
la mort d'un frère d'un père ou d'un
fils elle ramène la mort par la maladie
c'est une claque un choc une forme de
brutalité du monde une première
mondialisation andreu d'autant plus que
la réunion souffre déjà énormément de sa
situation géographique à quelques
centaines de kilomètres seulement à
l'ouest des côtes réunionnaises
il y à cette gigantesque concurrentes
qui va l'écraser de tout son poids
madagascar conquise par les français à
la fin du 19e siècle
il faut essayer d'imaginer cette
proximité entre la réunion et madagascar
et d'un seul coup cette immense île
n'est le rouge comme on l'appelait à
l'époque avaient toutes ces richesses
réelles va totalement place non de la
réunion qui n'apportait pas autant de
richesses qu'il n'y avait pas autant de
valeur pour la métropole
madagascar c'était beaucoup plus
intéressant du fait de la présence de ce
port stratégique très intéressant diego
suarez ou débouché du canal de suez
donc ça va devenir aussi la roue de
pétrolières jusqu'aux années 70 c'est un
des principaux points d'appui français
dans l'océan indien et la réunion va se
retrouver paupérisée donc pas simplement
par le développement propre à lille mais
parce que tous les investissements là
terraine la métropole va se porter sur
madagascar est une île qui est plus de
200 fois plus importante que la réunion
donc aussi avec un potentiel énorme en
terres agricoles on l'a dit mais en
ressources forestières minières en main
d'oeuvre il ya vingt fois plus
d'habitants et donc il va y avoir ce
sentiment la réunion d'avoir été oubliés
par la métropole oublié par la mère
patrie comme s'ils voulaient certaine
manière les réunionnais n'était pas
reconnu dans l'imaginaire collectif
[Musique]
ce cauchemar vieux d'un siècle n'est
plus qu'un lointain souvenir pour les
réunionnais d'aujourd'hui un vague
souvenir même quand on voit ce qu'est
devenue celle que toutes les brochures
touristiques ont baptisée l'île intense
la réunion qui attire chaque année plus
d'un demi million de visiteurs
une sorte d' ailleurs domestiquer la
réunion depuis les années 60 70
il ya un rattrapage il ya beaucoup
d'équipements sanitaires etc et donc le
tourisme c'est quand même à remplacer la
canne à sucre
donc c'est un atout important c'est un
lieu qui voilà qui ne repousse plus ses
habitants
le fait de revenir voir de se
réinstaller dans leur île
ça montre bien effectivement que on y
attacher un conte a fait plus ce qui
pouvait être le cas dans le passé pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux
[Musique]
aurélie est né à la réunion et a dû la
quitter un jour par obligation elle a
passé quatre années en métropole
loin de chez elle le temps de faire ses
études
et puis un jour elle a décidé de rentrer
à la maison
malgré toutes les difficultés qu'ils
attendaient ça dépend des branches on a
l'impression quand même au jour
d'aujourd'hui on favorise
les gens venant de l'extérieur métropole
ou à l'étranger
c'est pas facile tous les jours
il ya beaucoup de métropolitains qui
viennent à la réunion par rapport aux
conditions de vie le soleil toute
l'année
l'indexation des salaires
tous les trous c'est
ça n'a pas de prix il ya des personnes
qui viennent
unis qui attire bien plus que les autres
les chiffres le prouvent
en 40 ans la population de la réunion a
doublé et lille est devenu le territoire
le plus peuplé de l'autre mer français
[Musique]
aurélie est diététicienne
elle a choisi d'aider ceux qui sont
touchés par une maladie à adapter leur
alimentation pour pouvoir vivre mieux
une façon de se tourner vers les autres
ceux qui sont nés ici comme elle
est ce que vous connaissez un petit peu
de ce diabète du coup au jour
d'aujourd'hui la définition de diabète
c'est trop de sucre dans le sang c'est
ça s'est fait à partir en métropole à ce
moment là c'était
wick a comparu une obligation parce que
si j'avais envie de se faire mes études
elle n'existait pas à la réunion qui il
fallait il fallait que je parte sinon
j'avais peut-être pointer au chômage ou
devoir me réorienter sur une autre
formation qui peut être me plairait pas
[Musique]
votre corps humain à l'intérieur du
corps humain j'ai galéré à avoir avoir
un bon
c'est pas je vais dire un peu sa
compacte tout les coins ronds et
c'est pas évident je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
j'aurais dû avoir un poste plus
important concerne j'ai des diplômes
donc au jour d'aujourd'hui je suis pas
encore arrivé au niveau de mon diplôme
en mahdia
[Musique]
bonjour pendant des mois un petit paquet
comme ça sur un joli schengen mètres de
là où je vais décrocher de prendre celui
là hop est bon merci bonne journée dans
les choses importantes pour moi revenir
à la réunion
c'était à cette diversité culturelle
cette visite et couleurs de peau de
religion de culture tournée mélanger
tourné ensemble sans différence et il
n'y a pas ce jugement
il ya aucune religion meilleur que
l'autre on peut avoir une église à côté
d'un d'un temple chinois he ou d'un
temple musulmans peu importe on est
vraiment tous ensemble il ya ya ya cette
tolérance ce ce c'est vraiment un
exemple je pense quasiment unique dans
le monde de vivre ensemble
[Musique]
le vivre ensemble réunionnais serait un
modèle du genre
de quoi renforcer le pouvoir
d'attraction exceptionnelle de lille une
immense bouffée d'air frais pour tous
ceux qui ont choisi de s'installer ici
[Musique]
ap regardes tu penses
abandonner ses petites fleurs et à la
paire ont refusé ou de bracelets
pourquoi je suis revenu ici à la plaine
des caps et c'est vraiment bas déjà
c'est nora c'est en fait c'est simple je
sais pas comment expliquer ça c'était
tellement fort c'est le folklore c'est
le paysage puis ce qui nous manque aussi
c'était c'était la famille faut pas se
le cacher à la famille on était vraiment
parti à la base tous les deux on s'est
agrandi entre temps mais c'est vraiment
le manque de ceux de cet entourage et de
ceux de ce ce paysage ce petit monde un
petit peu comme tu disais tout à l'heure
un petit peu oui on est isolé à la fois
on a on a tous quoi tu entends tu as
retrouvé un badge donc moi j'entends les
petits oiseaux écoute écoute écoute on à
paris
[Musique]
c'est le premier noël de raphaël à ces
bus qui ça on a l'impression que c'était
loin ça fait loin c'est c'est une autre
vie c'est je suis passé c'est cool aussi
oui oui parce que c'était c'était une
autre histoire
c'est pas la même ça on a l'impression
vraiment que c'était oui on aura
l'occasion j'espère de refaire du ski ou
là par exemple on voit là ont testé en
touche et ont expérimenté le froid la
neige les boules de neige et la bêtise
s'amuser on joue on ne va pas le manque
a commencé à vraiment être à est
vraiment fort c'est quand on a commencé
à fêter les anniversaires de raphaël
donc là on avait une photo ici on
appelait sur l'ordinateur de notre
famille parce que si on fait quoi voilà
et
on lui faisait souffler ses bougies
devant papy mamie pour qu'ils
participent un peu malgré tout malgré la
distance finalement même si c'était bien
ça nous rappelle qu'on était quand même
un peu seul
en fait ce sera sûrement le cas aussi
pour nos enfants un moment donné il me
disait maman j'ai envie de devenir
astronaute c'était ça le dernier métier
je pense que astronautes à la réunion
c'est un peu c'est un peu compliqué donc
à ce moment là moi je me prépare déjà
dans ma petite tête qu'elle fasse ses
valises un et quinze jours il partira
et voilà la fin de l'histoire
un voyage dans l'espace en forme de rêve
d'enfant pour clore notre rêve à nous
celui d'un voyage dans le temps
celui qui nous poursuit au fur et à
mesure que ces clichés se sont révélés
sous nos yeux
l' envie de voir cet autre monde
complexe torturé faire machine arrière
d'un petit siècle seulement pour
entendre enfin le son de ces voies surgi
du passé nous conter leurs histoires
leurs angoisses leurs espoirs leurs
doutes
de l'épopée des pionniers du ciel
guyanais à la victoire de la communauté
indienne de guadeloupe du mythe de la
beauté polynésienne à la descente aux
enfers réunionnaise sans oublier les
origines de la terre de champions
martiniquaise regarder enfin en face
cette réalité vieille d'un siècle figé
en une fraction de seconde sur papier
glacé
une rencontre entre deux époques
l'une martyrisé par l'enfer de la
colonisation il ya tout juste cent ans
et l'autre la nôtre avec ses progrès
certes mais aussi ses incertitudes
car les séquelles de cette période
trouble de l'histoire n'ont pas disparu
avec le temps et ses photos sont là pour
nous rappeler qu'un siècle s'est
finalement bien peu pour oublier
[Musique]
et